companion experiences for Microsoft
teams meetings video meetings
traditionally limit each person to one
device but many meeting tasks would be
easier with two devices and works at a
table in a design studio with a
Microsoft Surface pro and mobile phone
in Microsoft teams you can use their
devices together and joins a Microsoft
teams video meeting on her surface pro
Bob and Cathar in the meeting and joins
her phone as a companion to her surface
pro in the meeting use your computer and
phone together to present live mobile
video and stands up and walks to a large
3d physical model of a pie chart and
stands in front of the physical pie
chart and selects share video from her
phones teams interface and sees a
preview of the video of the physical pie
chart and presses start presenting and
the video from her phone can be seen
maximized on Bob and Katz views of the
meeting she moves around the model
pointing at various parts use her
computer and phone together to take and
present photos and chooses share photo
from the menu and gets ready to take a
picture of color guides pinned to the
wall
she takes the photo and presses start
presenting Bob and cath see the photo
she returns to her table puts the phone
down and talks about the photo use your
computer and phone together to continue
your meeting on-the-go and looks at her
watch and tells Bob and calf that she
has to leave and picks up her phone and
turns on camera microphone and speaker
she talks to Bob and cast as she shuts
her surface pro and walks away
use your computer and phone together to
present your phone screen the next day
and is in a lecture hall which is also a
teams meeting Dave and Ed are watching
remotely on her phone and starts the
edge web browser and Scrolls down a web
page the computer shows a mirrored view
and Dave and Ed see the same view the
lecture hall audience sees and walking
around presenting her phone screen use
your computer and phone together to
remote-control power point in the
lecture Anne's phone and computers show
a PowerPoint presentation Dave and Edie
see the same presentation the lecture
hall audience sees and walking around
presenting her phone to remote control
PowerPoint presented by Microsoft